foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's keynote webinar
titled after the mandates end preparing
for the next covid-19 variant this
webinar is a part of the coronavirus
virtual event series the seventh in the
series
I'm antonina Salcido of collaborates and
I will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab results
how let's get started before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
I now present today's speaker Dr Abraham
flaxman associate professor of Health
metric Sciences Institute for health
metrics and evaluation at the University
of Washington
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr flaxman you may
now begin your presentation
oh great thanks so much thanks for
having me and thanks for coming everyone
as you heard my name is Abraham flaxman
and I'm going to tell you today about
the ihme covid-19 projection model an
update on where we're at now
here's a outline of where I'm planning
to go in this talk Falls broadly into
three parts first about the model we'll
talk about the model structure including
some of our more recent Innovations to
capture waning immunity uh we'll talk
about how we fit past data in the model
which is the necessary step to making
our future projections and we'll talk
about some Omicron specific attributes
that we've incorporated into the model
and in fact just with a model fitting
past data with omicron's specific
attributes I think I can share with you
some pretty interesting findings about
how we've gotten to where we are we'll
then turn to our forecasts conditional
projections where we try to say where we
might be heading
and conclude with some reflection on
future variants a really big question
mark in all of this as you heard we
encourage questions and I hope to have
plenty of time for questions at the end
of this presentation
now
to begin with
ihme covid-19 projection model
this model is really the fourth edition
of version 4.0 if you like of a covid
projection model that we've been working
on for over two years now at ihme uh and
most recently we've been around
elaborating the model for variance and
for waning immunity
uh knowing so much now
not so much knowing more now about
waning immunity we've learned that the
time since infection or the time since
vaccination is a critical attribute to
keep track of in a model in order to
accurately capture patterns of waiting
immunity and this has led us to
reformulate yet again our model which
has gone from a curve fitting model
through a mathematical epidemiological
model based on differential equations to
our current formulation this model
formulation requires using integral
differential equations meaning there's
not just sort of derivatives talking
about how things change over time but
also integrals uh
in the expression of those derivatives
and for an example of what I mean here
uh this is the only time I'll say
integral in the rest of this talk I
think if we denote by Epsilon of Tau the
efficacy of a vaccine
Tau days after it's Peak efficacy then
um
PSI of Tau denotes the number of
individuals who are vaccinated uh PSI of
t on day T this convolution integral
from 0 to T PSI of T minus Tau times 1
minus Epsilon of Tau D tau is a way to
quantify the kind of overall protection
of the population
from That vaccine
at time T based on the vaccination
across the entire time course
and by using this sort of relation for
both
infection
acquired immunity and vaccine acquired
immunity based on all of the different
vaccines and all of the different
variants we've seen so far that's really
the heart at this point of our
simulation model to understand
where the disease is going
NOW essential in putting this all
together is that Epsilon of Tau vaccine
Effectiveness as a function of time this
sort of waning immunity and my
colleagues have been working hard to
assemble all of the available
information and then make some sort of
extrapolation to say where do we think
waning immunity is headed over time you
can see on this slide dots of different
sizes showing the different evidence
that we do have and then lines that
become dashed lines as they become more
and more speculative about where this
immunity might be waning towards in the
future
you can also see uh say in the middle of
that plot that 50 weeks after the second
dose we expect all of these available
vaccines to have waned substantially in
their effectiveness at preventing
infection now when it comes to seeing
how an outbreak spreads infection is a
very important parameter but when it
comes to seeing how an outbreak affects
us all it's severe disease that's it
perhaps even more important parameter
and so separately from that previous
slide showing the waning effectiveness
of preventing infection my colleagues
have also worked hard to similarly
quantify their weighting effectiveness
of preventing severe disease and as you
can see here uh same picture so the same
sort of interpretation these dots
represent data and then the solid lines
represent our best fit through the day
data and then they become dashed lines
showing our best effort extrapolation
out Beyond those uh measurements that we
now have in hand and so you can see from
this that at week uh 50 after the second
dose there's substantially more
protection especially from the Pfizer
moderna mRNA vaccines that we're
assuming in our model as compared to
preventing infection we do think that
there is still going to be important
prevention of severe disease
now over the last year or the last 18
months really we have come to understand
just how important representing variance
is also in this model and in particular
since the rise of Omicron we have
realized just how essential it is to
understand the level of infection
derived protection from past variants
against current variants this Matrix
shows the assumptions that we've put
into our model that for example
infection from uh the alpha variant
confers some protection against the beta
gamma and Delta variance but less
protection against Omicron uh we use
this admittedly speculative relation to
capture the idea that Omicron really was
able to escape the immune response uh
both to some people who have uh been
vaccinated but importantly also to
people who have protection from a past
infection
and on top of that variant sort of uh
immunity or lack of immunity we also
have a important part of the model
looking at the natural waning the waning
of the immunity conferred by an
infection as shown on the right now
overlaid is both the protection against
future infections shown in blue and the
protection against hospitalization and
death shown in Orange
just as with vaccines we believe that
there will be more protection against
hospitalization and death say 50 weeks
out then there is will be against uh
infection and so putting together this
immunity remaining X days Tau days since
infection with the cross variant
immunities shown in the uh Matrix on the
left hand side is how the model
represents the infection derived
protection
and with all of this model structure
with all of this you know uh best
estimates on waning immunity we are now
in a place to fit our model to all of
the available past data and this next
slide shows an example of the data that
we have in hand and how we are able to
estimate past infections using this
model by fitting the model to the data
this is real data it comes from Colorado
is just an Exemplar Colorado is
geographic unit
528 in our work and that means there are
many other Geographic units which we are
fitting in the same way
and what you can see on the left hand
column of this slide is the different
sort of daily updated data sources that
are most essential for fitting our model
in the top is one of the data sources
that I see coming up most in say news
coverage of what's happening with covid
uh daily case counts
and these are a really important source
of information they're reported
regularly they're clearly linked to
what's happening with disease as you can
see with that really dramatic peak of
the Delta wave in the daily cases on the
other hand they have some severe
limitations for example
the number of cases is really dependent
on
how many people are getting tested and
how they're getting tested uh you know
there's a lot of at-home testing
happening now and that's great for
people knowing whether they uh can
safely go about their routines or
whether they need to take more
protective measures uh but that is uh
not making it necessarily into our data
system and so you can see in the middle
column one of the important challenges
in interpreting this is understanding
the infection detection ratio how many
infections are being confirmed as cases
because the thing that is never measured
routinely that I really really want to
know about is the number of infections
that is to say the the cases that are
confirmed and the cases if you like that
do not make it through the system to
being officially confirmed
so despite the timeliness of the green
curve it has a lot of challenges in
interpretation and that brings us to the
blue and red curves
the red curve is the daily death rate
that's another one that I see reported
on a lot of the time in the popular
media and it is also a very important
sort of marker for What's Happening Here
uh it is in my opinion gonna have a lot
more accuracy than the cases because
there's a you know a lot of care put
into certifying deaths in Colorado and
in the United States in high income
settings in general uh and on the other
hand it has some major challenges as
well uh most importantly
um the infections as I said the things
that is most important to me for
understanding what's happening with this
course of this pandemic are happening
roughly three weeks before deaths from
covid in those uh most severe bad
outcomes and so it's really a lagging
indicator it's in some ways the ultimate
lagging indicator uh another challenge
has been the change in the infection
fatality rate and you can see in that
middle column bottom panel how we have
both observed and modeled the change in
infection fatality rate both as Health
Systems have learned how better to deal
with covet infections and as the
variants have changed and vaccines have
become more widespread and uh past
infections have conferred some
additional protection to the lead to a
much lower rate of deaths from
infections
from a public health perspective of
course this is great news we really are
lucky that this disease has become less
severe over time from the perspective of
sort of
projecting uh mapping even estimating
past infections as a modeler it is a
challenge though because this means that
the signal that comes out of these death
counts is getting weaker and so that
brings us to the middle panel which is
sort of a hybrid you know captures some
of the strengths of cases and some of
the strengths of daily deaths coming
from daily Hospital admissions
um
and as you would guess from the name
this is the count of people every day
who are being admitted to the hospital
the cost of their covet uh this is
probably going to capture a more
representative kind of window of what's
happening with the disease than cases uh
and on the other hand it's not going to
be lagging so far behind infections as
deaths and so what you can see in the
right hand panel is the way that each of
these uh different data sources maps to
infections according to our model as
well as a kind of consensus estimate
putting together all three that's that
top right panel showing in different
colors the estimated daily infections
from the different single data sources
and then in Black the kind of model
based uh consensus estimate from those
different data sources
the middle panel on the right hand row
is one that I think is a really
important in some ways uh cross check
of these different approaches what it
looks like at
is zero prevalence surveys and the
cumulative percent of people infected
based on these serial prevalence surveys
so the sort of
different sources of daily information
are really essential to estimating past
infections the way I think about it and
the zero surveys are part of this
estimation as well but to me they're
also a really important cross check to
see is this kind of making sense
consistently and finally in the bottom
right panel log beta is sometimes uh
thought of as the forces infection this
is uh not the kind of reproductive
number r that is often bandied about but
it's very closely related to it the
lower it is the less infections are
leading to new infections and so you can
see kind of throughout this whole
picture all of the different pieces that
go into estimating past infections
said
this is an example from Colorado so just
as an additional point of comparison
I'll show you uh the same sort of
picture from the state I grew up in a
geographic unit
536 or as
others call it
the state of Illinois and again we have
the same picture here where daily cases
is shown in Green in the top left and as
I mentioned that has some limitations
but we triangulate with daily Hospital
admissions shown in blue and daily
deaths shown in red these three daily
sources are converted according to the
infection detection rate infection
hospitalization rate and infection
fatality rate as shown in the middle
column to give three
estimates of daily infections shown in
different colors in the upper right
and in both of these if you really key
in on that figure in the upper right
you'll see that on the one hand these
show that the peak of Omicron was way
way higher than what we were looking at
today or in this picture at the end of
March and on the other hand it's all
about framing right if you look at
what's happening at the end of March
that's a daily infection rate as high as
any of the daily infection rate Peaks
from waves before Omicron
so
um the middle panel on the rightmost
column I think is another important one
for kind of uh cross checking this work
and in Illinois there is a zero
prevalence survey from around the peak
of omocross giving us some additional
evidence that this kind of cumulative
number infected has gotten really high
during the Omicron wave
with all of this sort of model in hand
fitting it to the available data as I've
described
we now can look at pretty interesting
things even without making projections
and so I'll take a brief detour here to
talk about how we've been estimating the
expected mortality and therefore the
excess mortality
due to covet and so I'll talk you
through the step one two three but
actually to give you a path to where
we're going look at the bottom plot of
those three plots and look at the
rightmost part of that bottom plot
there's a red line vertical line and
then to the right of that red line you
see a sort of scalloped blue curve I'll
tell you where we got that from that's
what we think
overall mortality would be like in the
United States this last year 2020 and
2021 had it not been for covid
those great dots on the other hand show
week by week what overall mortality was
like in the United States
as we saw it in the world
and so the area between that scallop
blue curve at the bottom and the curve
traced out by those gray dots at the top
is a way to quantify the excess
mortality that is to say not just the
direct deaths due to covid but also the
direct deaths to covid that weren't
counted and also on top of that the
indirect deaths that might have happened
for example because of drug overdoses
while people were social distancing and
drug use became much riskier or heart
attacks because hospitals were
overwhelmed and perhaps weren't able to
provide the cardiovascular care that
they would have in the non-covered
period And so this is the kind of thing
that with a model with all this data
even without getting into projections we
were able to provide uh and I think that
I think that we've got plenty of time
for me to tell you a little bit about
the quantity nerdy details of how we got
that scallop line before showing you
what it tells us about the world
how we got it so step one is to group
all of the data on total mortality by
weeks or really by months uh I'm sorry
but by by weeks and months and then fit
this overall trend uh you can see in the
U.S it's by weeks in some places we only
know month by month
uh and that's sort of the figure 2A
picture in the upper left of those three
panels that shows the fit that the solid
Blue Line uh curving through those
Wiggly points
step two is after counting uh counting
for this weekly Trend we then fit the
residuals across years to get the time
Trend and so basically after taking out
seasonal uh variation that's the figure
2B in the upper right
and that shows that year over year
perhaps there was a little bit of an
increase in uh overall mortality rate
then leveling out and perhaps a little
bit of a decrease uh coming into the
current time
and of course stopping this prediction
before the coveted period
and then step three is to take that
extrapolated time trend from figure 2B
and sum up the weak trend from figure 2A
to get the overall trend the scallop
blue Curves in the bottom panel uh and
of course we have to do this separately
by age and by sex because both of these
are such important determinants of
mortality uh we do it for all of the
locations with available data and that's
how we're able to put together a map
not just of what's happening in USA But
globally of the excess mortality rate
during the coven period 2020 to 2021
this is really striking uh to look at
and is in some ways a bit of a different
story than what you see looking at
coveted case counts now first of all
there are some things that I think uh
really jump out of this uh from the
range of the excess mortality rates
around the world because there are some
places that pursue a coveted zero
strategy and had actually
uh excess mortality rate less than zero
meaning actually less deaths uh during
the covet period or you know say even
less than 10 per hundred thousand I
think would be considered a really
successful sort of coveted suppression
strategy you can see that especially
popping out in Australia and New Zealand
which had very successful coveted zero
strategies during the first waves of the
pandemic as well as in China outside of
uh you know the uh Wuhan area
um
then you can also see that there are
some countries which were able to keep
to that 50 to 100 excess mortality per
hundred thousand person years but many
countries were in these different
intensity shades of orange uh and many
states in the United States as well
showing that excess mortality rates uh
were very high in some places and uh I
think you know seeing this in South
America and in Eastern Europe
uh maybe even in the Middle East
consistent with a lot of the kind of uh
the news coverage based on what's being
reported in cases but I think it is a
surprise to see uh some of the patterns
in sub-Saharan Africa especially
Southern sub-Saharan Africa uh and also
Eastern sub-Saharan Africa where uh
perhaps the uh picture went looking only
at what has been confirmed cases would
have found uh something that
does not recognize the extent to which
covet led to excess mortality in these
parts of the world
um so one more part of model structure
and then I can get into some of the
forecasts
but it has become overwhelmingly clear
over the last six months that our model
needs some Omicron specific changes
first of all the speed at which Omicron
has spread through the world has just
been off the charts compared to what we
had previously modeled so this slide
shows empirically days since there was
one percent of Omicron detected from
these surveillance systems looking at
the percent of different variants within
a population
uh and the data marks for that day since
one present are then kind of summarized
by that red curve that just shoots up
and in fact
fits the lower parts of those data
points but actually is even slower than
the a few data points where we have a
really good measurement of the complete
invasion of Omicron
uh to compare that to something
Delta
which seemed really fast when it was
taking over the world last summer is
shown in black and
this is a parameterized model so we can
also say well what if we had something
like Delta but it was going twice as
fast shown in blue is still nowhere near
the speed at which I'm a crowd invaded
more than twice as fast as Delta in this
model's parametrization
and then secondly it's very important
that we capture the vaccine
Effectiveness which is lower for Omicron
and so a very important part of this
model is uh including our best estimates
of the effectiveness of different
vaccines for presenting different
preventing different variants of covet
both in terms of preventing the
infection important for the spread of
disease and preventing the progression
uh the column here called severe disease
and as you can see looking across all of
these columns all of these rows we have
assumed that Omicron is just going to be
much more successful in evading the
protection conferred by these vaccines
if you look at for example AstraZeneca
that Top Line severe disease from Delta
uh we believe there's a 94 percent
Effectiveness but for Omicron that drops
to 71 even more striking for the
infection I'm looking now in the middle
row for the moderna vaccine where uh
evidence that we've assembled says we're
going to assume a 91 percent
Effectiveness for preventing uh
infection that's going to drop for
Omicron to 48 effectiveness
uh and if you're thinking back to the
time I spent telling you about the
importance of waning immunity in this
model these estimates are the initial
Effectiveness after two doses of the
vaccine so remember that all of these
are going to weigh in over time and that
48 percent uh Effectiveness for
preventing infection from moderna for
example uh is going to wane over time
we think that Effectiveness against
preventing Omicron actually wanes more
quickly perhaps than Effectiveness for a
previous variance and so at our model
we're assuming that there will be only
10 to 15 percent Effectiveness after 20
weeks
of course
as additional data a cruise we would be
able to update this based on additional
evidence
and so to summarize the key attributes
of Omicron that we've had to adjust
to incorporate into our model first of
all how infectious it is highly
infectious variant several times uh
faster taking over than Delta
secondly
um it seems to be less severe and 80 to
90 percent uh in our model of infections
We Believe will be asymptomatic or mild
in symptoms this is based on for example
evidence from South African clinical
trial enrollees where there was a 31
Point prevalence detected in early
December despite many people having no
or mild symptoms also kind of consistent
with observations about pre-hospital
admission screening uh patients who are
going to the hospital for something
totally unrelated to covid and get a
covid test that shows that they're
covered positive despite being
asymptomatic this has been as high as 10
percent in U.S hospitals during the
Omicron surge or the ons in the UK has
uh surveys that have found 12 prevalence
in some regions again with the ability
to check how much is Asics automatic or
mild symptoms
and so uh in combination this is going
to lead to a 40 to 60 percent reduction
in the in uh case to hospitalization
rate
[Music]
has observed to have a large 80
reduction in hospital fatality rate in
some data available from South Africa
and Canada
but as mentioned
uh this is traded off against what uh
you can think of of immune Escape people
who have previously been infected or
even previously been vaccinated uh are
more likely to be re-infected by Omicron
uh and in this model again uh we have
had to include an assumption of 50 of
previously infected individuals could
get infected Again by Omicron
having now thoroughly immersed you in
the model structure I'll give you a
little bit of a picture of where it's
going and this is something that you can
also investigate online using our web
tool
covid19.healthdata.org I find it can be
very interesting to dig into specific
locations that are relevant with uh
specific audiences for you I have
focused very generally
and to summarize what our Global picture
looks like uh there's a massive wave of
infection spreading through all regions
in the world but just taking off in
China outside of certain key regions
and what we have observed from this
Omicron wave is that the wave peaks in
20 to 30 days after an exponential rise
in cases
uh and there have been secondary waves
observed from what people are calling
subvariants of Omicron va2 replaced ba1
in multiple locations in Europe uh and
this sort of extended anoma Crown wave
when the ba2 subvariant came in uh those
countries often had about another 21
days
of wave
we estimate from this model that more
than 60 percent of the world is likely
to be infected with Omicron once this
wave is complete
and we're really we believe at the tail
end of this wave now as this wave ends
it's going to leave the world with the
highest levels of immunity since the
beginning of the pandemic
but as I've gone over this immunity will
Wane over time
to give you a picture at the kind of
national level for the United States
uh our model showing infections the
thing I'm most interested in on the left
says in three different scenarios
whether we keep going as we think we've
been going in the reference scenario or
are able to increase uptake of a third
dose of vaccines uh or are able to
increase greatly the amount of mass use
which seems to be just the opposite of
our strategic approach we are headed for
a low number of infections over the
summer
and of course framing is so important
here that low number of infections looks
tiny compared to the peak of Omicron at
4 million infections per day and on the
other hand if you were to zoom in and
look at where our model said we were uh
at the beginning of April you'd see
actually it's of similar magnitude to
any of the previous Peaks shown here how
important framing is the right hand
panel is the version of infections
that's easier for you to use to check my
work reported cases shows a similar
story of course instead of Omicron
infections peaking at 4 million per day
confirmed cases peaked at the same time
at 800 000 per day that's because of
that infection detection ratio that is
changing over time that makes it so hard
to interpret reported cases
um being in global Public Health uh you
know I'm keyed in on not just what the
infections are but what are the severe
uh consequences of these infections and
so it is really reassuring to see that
this model forecasts daily deaths in the
United States
similarly tapering off and low over the
summer
and this is an important combination of
those various factors that I reviewed of
over Omicron that despite the uh peak of
Omicron being so much higher in terms of
infections that corresponding peak in
February at the peak of daily deaths was
actually not as high as previous
uh kind of severest severe outcomes Peak
and so because of the level of
protection conferred by both vaccination
and virus we believe that over the
summer there will be a fewer than kind
of ever before daily deaths from covid
of course looking forward to all of this
we must be concerned with the
subvariants and we've already seen what
you might think of as the ba2 Omicron
subvariant shoulder uh some countries in
Europe but not all but countries
including the UK France Germany and the
Netherlands have had a sort of secondary
wave after their first wave of Omicron
subsided driven by the ba2 subvariant
and these waves have lasted 18 to 22
days uh and so a ba2 wave or later
variants a subvariance is quite possible
in the United States I'm talking to you
from Seattle and we're perhaps making it
through one right now uh but we may have
at a national level a minimal ba2 plus
wave similar to what was observed in
Spain due to the higher levels of past
infections in the U.S
and so this
slide coming towards the end of my deck
shows in summary or estimate of how
immunity has increased and now has begun
to decline across the United States
shown in the darker lower line is the
percent of people who are immune to
Omicron at each point in time
and that is lower than the percent of
people immune to Delta currently but
that's because Omicron is able to escape
some of the immunity conferred by Delta
and Delta's not around very much anymore
it's really this Omicron curve showing
that we peaked at around 70 percent of
people protected and have started our
slow decline due to vaccine and viral
waning
um and so this is the picture that goes
into our model going forward of how many
people are protected now this is based
on very important assumptions about the
emergence of new variants
but our model is what I like to think of
as a conditional projection projection
assuming that there are not in the next
three months new variants substantially
different from what we've seen so far
and so
I think that that is where we will
really be wrapping this up my final bit
is just to say we have these great
unknowns and for 18 months I've been
talking about the model that we have
worked on but concluding that the great
unknown is variance
that is still the case
and so what uh we can say based on what
we've seen so far is that new variants
are highly likely to emerge
and on the other hand even variants that
have higher severity were one to emerge
that uh compared to Omicron led to more
hospitalizations and more severe
outcomes from my colleagues kind of
observations and discussions with uh
Public Health decision makers and key
stakeholders we have this big concern
that there's fatigue for social
distancing and even variants that have
higher severity may not lead to
government social distancing mandates
coming back on
with this in mind it's important to
think about combinations of enhanced
levels of immunity ongoing vaccination
drives including appropriately timed
booster campaigns uh the scaling up and
making more widely available
anti-virals that can be used to treat
people when they develop more severe
illness
and health knowledge about ways that
people especially people who are
vulnerable can protect themselves
through high quality mask use uh and
through their own social distancing are
really important to have this kind of
multi-layered Defense in the uh era that
we are now in knowing about the high
uncertainty of variance to come
a combination of these measures
should be really effective in reducing
future death toll if a new more damaging
variant does arise
and so uh my colleagues looking forward
think that the place we should be
thinking is this final bullet covid-19
will become a disease that Health
Systems need to manage on an ongoing
basis and there's a lot of talk about
what's an epidemic and what's an endemic
let's not get into the semantics of that
the important thing is uh when SARS one
went away it was a miracle uh we might
have been hoping for that with Sarah's
Cove too but I think at this point we
have to recognize that
kind of uh
covid-19
in some form is here to stay
so I believe I will leave it at that I
don't know what happens when I click
next on my final slide looks like it
just stays on that slide uh and I thank
you all for your attention and we'll now
move to questions
yes thank you Dr flaxman for informative
presentation
um we're going to now start the Q a
portion of the webinar and if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
now let's get started we already have a
few questions
um one my first question is when we
speak about waning immunity we mean that
mRNA based immunity waning really fast
why is it still a problem to bring dead
virus based vaccines in the U.S and the
rest of the Western countries like
co-vaccine for example which which does
have a long lasting and adaptive
cellular memory
um uh this is a great question
unfortunately a little bit outside of my
expertise so I do not feel like uh it's
one that I can answer
um I think that in general you know
there has been a lot of focus on these
mRNA vaccines uh and other really
Innovative new platforms for vaccines
and I think on the one hand this has
been a big bet that has really paid off
you know the two mRNA vaccines kind of
from conception to proof of concept at
90 plus efficacy in a year is heroic is
amazing and I'm so thankful and grateful
to the uh the the scientists who've made
that possible on the other hand you know
there's been a huge gap in getting these
new Innovations to the world and
vaccines don't respect our borders uh if
we can't vaccinate the world we're still
at risk for new variants emerging and so
I think that in general and again this
is outside of my expertise the idea of
coming up with alternative approaches to
these mRNA vaccines that are uh perhaps
more scalable the more able to reach the
world that has not yet been reached by
mRNA I think is a very valuable part of
our approach even with those promising
plots that I showed you you know as I
concluded I think kovid is here with us
to stay and we've got to be looking for
approaches that are going to protect the
world on a regular basis
thanks
for that response another question has
the rise of sub-variance ba4 and ba5 in
South Africa and or ba2 12.1 in the U.S
led to any changes to these projections
this is a really important question and
as I said you know we've seen these kind
of ba2 sub-variants extending the uh
length of the Omicron wave compared to
what our model initially projected in
some of the countries in Europe with the
enough surveillance for us to really see
that we uh missed a bit
our model currently treats these
additional subvariants in the same way
and so that is to say that our model
somewhat optimistically assumes that
there's going to be this fall off after
about three weeks of Omicron but as
these subvariants rise it can sort of
slow the decline and so that's this kind
of ba2 shoulder effect that we see in
the data I think that any one of these
additional subvariants could have that
same prolonging prolonging of the
decline what we will see as we continue
to update our model based on available
data is probably some of these
optimistic tailings off
um taking longer than was projected uh
before we had that available data on
subvariants but we do not expect this to
lead to an additional dramatic rise
especially in the parts that I think are
most severe like the hospitalization and
death panels of those data slides that
we were looking at earlier
thanks
thank you for your response and I think
we're going to wrap up with this last
question does an infection by Omicron
protect from other variants and for how
long
oh don't I wish I knew this is a really
key question and it is one that I think
as we see more and learn more about
subvariance and what is to come next
we will find out of course uh you saw
that we have gone out on a limb and made
these projections of how long
we think that uh the level of immunity
our population has acquired both through
vaccination and through infection is
going to last going into the summer we
expect that the protection against Delta
is going to be declining that the
protection against Omicron is going to
be declining but really what is
important is what is to come next and uh
what we're hoping and have seen so far
in the available evidence is that the
Omicron subvariants are not
um leading to an additional spike in
confirmed cases certainly not a spike in
hospitalizations or deaths so my hope is
yes
that an infection uh will protect
against other variants for at least you
know months but uh certainly this is a
big big question mark right now uh one
that we'll be watching for very closely
thank you
thank you Dr flaxman do you have any
final comments for our audience
um you know I just really appreciate the
chance to uh show you this work and get
a chance to talk through it all with you
uh because of the amount of time that we
had and the uh desire not to put in too
many integrals or other technical
details uh it might come off like these
beautiful lines showing what is going to
happen are certain but I think it's
really important that modelers have some
humility about what our models project
and I hope that I have made you think
you know this is what might happen if
this and if that and if the other thing
hold I hope that it's useful to have
these conditional projections but I hope
that it doesn't come off like I know the
future and I'm sure of these things
because as I've tried to emphasize there
really are so many important unknowns
still at this point
thank you very much
thank you again Dr flaxman for your time
today and your important research before
we go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we do
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until May 4th of 2024. lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time good time